last time we talked you were very uh
candid about
twitter and how you've been having some
issues with your twitter account because
like some of us you like to have a drink
or two and then get on twitter
and that can lead to issues i've deleted
my twitter account
you deleted it yeah on my own like no
one told me kirsten you should get off
twitter i just deleted it
i just it's so much going on
and it's toxic or something high school
yeah i can't i can't yeah i think i
think you're
i think you have the right approach you
described
twitter uh recently as being stuck at a
bad
party is that how it feels to you 100
i realized when i was saying it too that
now you don't get stuck at parties
because we have
like chauffeurs on our phones
but when i was in high school i would
always my friends were so bad
i was the good kid i just want to be
clear and we would
they'd be like it's fine girl like he's
gonna drive us to the party he doesn't
drink
it's gonna be all good and then we get
there and we're stuck he's doing drugs
not drinking but he might as well be
right and then he's not get the party
you're like i don't want to be here i
hate everybody here
and i keep coming back every weekend and
that's what twitter feels like to me
every time i'm there i'm like why didn't
i come back and i'm stuck right
that sounds that sounds rough kirsty let
me tell you what my experience was
nobody invited me to a party
nobody no that's the thing nobody was
ever invited to the party
it's not it's not a part of your your
anyone's invited to it's like a party
that ends because you hear gunshots
those yeah
well that's that's different okay yeah
yeah no
i didn't different high school we went
to it sounds like
i sound well first of all we went to
different high schools but i think uh
and
i will be honest with you there were no
gunshots
uh going off in brookline massachusetts
let me say that
but at the same time at the same time
if i had gone to your high school guess
what no one would have invited me to a
party
that's i would have i would have invited
you you would have invited me and maybe
you could have been the designated
driver and i wouldn't feel the way that
i feel
if you had invited me to the party
people would have said why'd you bring
that weird white lady with you
why's mom at the party what's with the
weird old white lady
what is she doing here